[Music]
did you poop during labor
so i was so scared that i was gonna poop
during labor i literally told my
boyfriend i was like if i poop please
don't tell me because i will be so
embarrassed
[Music]
was your pregnancy planned absolutely
not
it was actually kinda
did we sit down and say hey
you want to have a baby because i want
to have a baby no
were we having sex unprotected yeah even
though i took a plan b literally like
five hours later
i still got pregnant and i asked the
doctor i was like how she was like you
were ovulating and basically the plan b
can't stop ovulation it can only prevent
ovulation
we were using condoms every time and i
don't know what happened anytime anyone
says like just get on birth control like
i was on birth control
and it still happened so were you and
your partner still sexually active while
you're pregnant
yes no because i was single i personally
did not notice a difference except for
when i was like really big because you
have to navigate that
but it was good it's so weird because
naturally i'm not a like over sexual
person
and during pregnancy i was very sexual
like
all the time and definitely after
pregnancy it vanished
i don't know if i'll ever be pregnant
again to find out if it could be good
but it was not it's not pleasant what
was labor like
um i cried a lot i cried
for like 20 hours straight my labor was
unexpectedly long it was 48 hours
they had to induce me because my water
was leaking but i wasn't getting
contractions and then when i actually
pushed
that wasn't bad at all because he came
out in like 10 minutes the bad part was
after
like having to pee and use the bathroom
and stuff i tore inside
when i gave when i had him so they had
to stitch up inside and it hurt for
literally a month as a black woman it's
scary to go into the hospital
my biggest fear was that i wasn't going
to have a natural
or a vaginal birth i didn't a c-section
is major surgery
your body is being cut open they're
moving your organs around
in this society the average woman
doesn't even have the ability to sit at
home
for six weeks and be like all right i'ma
heal from major surgery
i did have an emergency c-section i
barely
remember it i felt like i was so hopped
up on drugs yes you
might be kind of numb but i definitely
felt like i could feel my doctor's hands
so deep inside of my stomach cavity
then they pulled her out and she cried
and it is true what they say like
it's one of the most beautiful sounds
ever after that not so much the first
cry
the best did you poop during labor so i
was so
scared that i was gonna poop during
labor i literally told my boyfriend i
was like if i poop please don't tell me
because i will be so embarrassed i
luckily didn't
i don't know they didn't tell me no i
did not poop during labor because i
didn't have to push
what happens is when you have a
c-section they have to make sure that
you actually
you know use the restroom before you
leave the hospital because the whole
process of
pulling a baby out via c-section is kind
of hard on your bowels
did you have any difficulties during
your pregnancy um
i had high blood pressure usually a
woman's blood pressure goes down
when she's pregnant mine stayed at what
they call a high
normal up until i was induced at 37
weeks pregnant
i fainted a couple of times just due to
like low
blood sugar i've never fainted before in
my life during my pregnancy i didn't
really have any difficulties
it was mostly during childbirth that i
did so my son's heart rate had dropped
like really bad while he was in my belly
they had to use like this little suction
thing to get to help help me push him
out because he wasn't coming out fast
enough
but my pregnancy actually was super like
a breeze i loved like having the belly
and everything
it was so cute by month two i'm like
okay i'm into this
and uh miscarried at 15 and a half weeks
it was definitely like
a very like traumatic experience i was
at home
and started cramping really bad and i
was like well something's definitely
wrong
and then started spotting and then just
like really really bloody
and i got myself into the shower because
i couldn't walk
and um
i think it was just more sad than
anything the physical side of it it was
really painful like
it literally felt like somebody was just
like stabbing my uterus like over and
over and like my
like just the whole the whole area i
called 9-1-1 and i was like i think
something's wrong i think it might be
miscarrying and they're like do you need
us to send somebody
no no like don't send anybody like i
can't afford an ambulance drive right
now
i was like don't send anybody and she's
like okay you just see me on the phone
with you and i was like yeah
she was really nice little southern lady
she was super sweet and just kind of
talked me through and like you're gonna
be okay
like everything's fine like and she told
me she's like okay it's gonna be really
weird but like go
to your gynecologist and so i called and
like made an emergency appointment for
the next day and like had to go in and
get the rest of everything like scraped
out
and i just laid there the whole time
like
embarrassed and sad and like i just
really wanted my mom
i think leaving the relationship i was
in at the time that i did was
probably the healthiest thing i've done
for myself in a really long time
and i have so much love for him like
very much still
involved in his life we're still really
close friends i think
knowing that like we both kind of get to
like move on
and like live our best lives in like the
healthiest manner
has been what's like getting me through
it did you consider having an abortion
would you have gotten an abortion
when i told my mom she was like okay let
me schedule your abortion appointment
and she did the morning of
the abortion appointment i told her like
i can't do it we did think about it we
thought about all of our options
no and that's because i was 26. girl
you you did this be a woman and have the
baby i made a decision to have an
abortion before i was even pregnant
i texted him i was like hey we need to
talk i'm pregnant
and i'm getting an abortion and he
started crying
which is totally fine but i remember
being like hey
like i'm the pregnant one here like i
want to cry can you comfort me
it's different for different people like
i didn't feel ashamed of the decision
but it's an emotional thing nonetheless
the worst part about it
were the just insane amount of adults
that were outside of the clinic
screaming in my face telling me to go to
hell and that i was a murderer when i
was 17 years old
it really like stands out as like a huge
part of the experience which is crazy
i went to planned parenthood in the
morning i remember they gave me the pill
like a little cup
like hey are you sure like once you take
this you can't go
like you cannot go back and i was like
yeah i'm sure and then i had to go get a
prescription for the second pills
because it's two pills medication
abortion
i think it was like eight hours nausea
and then vomiting
cramping bleeding diarrhea
sometimes all happening at the same time
i do
want to be a mom and i had an abortion
because i want to be a good mom when i'm
ready
i considered it i did it and i do not
regret it at all
this is a gonna be a hard one how was
your perception of your body image
and how has it changed i wanted to look
pregnant
i didn't want to be a fat person who was
pregnant and nobody knew it's definitely
hard to look at my stomach and see
like the loose skin and the weird weight
gain that happens in different areas
that's super hard to get rid of
throughout my adolescence i struggled
with an eating disorder
i was hospitalized for it multiple times
it was just really hard
to watch my body create something so
beautiful and so magical to me
and to shame myself for it and to feel
out of control
and because that's what an eating
disorder is all about is managing
and controlling everything in your life
after my pregnancy
it was even more challenging it was my
job and my duty
to make sure that my daughter was fed
from me and to not let like
the physical self get in the way of
making sure that i'm taking care and
nurturing my child
do you regret getting pregnant not even
a little bit
i never regretted it like even when i
found out it wasn't something where i
was like this is a mistake
i regret the partner i don't regret the
pregnancy
i feel like that's like weird because i
would like expect to be like did you
regret getting an abortion but do you
get
getting pregnant i feel like no one's
ever asked me that question before
i love my son like i think it's the best
thing that ever happened to me and i
think that being a young mom was for me
i honestly wouldn't have it any other
way i love it
i had all those emotions and then i had
all the opposite emotions i'm like oh my
gosh what am i gonna do
none of my friends are gonna like me
anymore because they're all like super
like jesusy which sounds terrible
because i am too
but then as soon as i told them that i
miscarried they're like why didn't you
tell us that you were pregnant we would
have done baby showers and all the
clothes and all the things
i feel like maybe yeah back in the day i
would have been like oh my god
absolutely like i wish i would have
never [ __ ] got pregnant but
now like i'm very aware that i am kind
of put here to be able to better
empathize and be compassionate towards
people and
i think i went through it for a reason
and i don't regret it
what is something you wish you had
learned sooner
i definitely wish i learned just a lot
more about
like birth control options and how easy
it is to get pregnant i wish that i'd
learn about sex period sooner
and i wish that it was more of an
everyday conversation
like we talk about food instead of oh my
god sex like it's like you know like
it's just so such a bad thing what i
learned
from my teenage years is that regardless
of what my mom said i was gonna find a
way to do what i wanted to do anyway
and it was just behind her back which
was just making it more dangerous for me
my goal is for my kids to be able to
trust me when it comes to things like
that
i don't know exactly how i'm going to do
that yet i just know that i want my
household to be very open
conversation wise
[Music]
you